oh Cantonese is good
you're chopping onions
here you go there's your knife
Joe had that in his nose by the way
[Music]
hello welcome to another amazing episode
of careful boys today we have geo with
us
you're a boy
um I think it's time we settle
once and for all what is the hottest
Asian accent really
hottest that's all we get just Asian
accents there's nothing why are you
acting like there's not a lot to pick
from huh
yeah hot that's the hottest one
I can't say yeah
if I'm very many Asian accents hot oh if
it's someone like Hawk his Asian accent
British British his British Asian hey
he's Asian he's got an accent not only
that that's Oxford British it is extra
British that's pretty hot it's very hot
I want that one you want that one oh God
that's what I that's my vote I any one
of those Asian accents particularly
turns you on Colleen
I guess Korean nothing seems to come to
mind you like that I mean I like that I
like a lot of K dramas dude that is true
they have really good romantic speak in
their drawings but I like it aren't they
speaking Korean though yeah oh right you
said accent accent yeah it has to be
English
I guess Korean Korean okay yeah I guess
Korean accent what do you want it to
sound like you do it what do I want what
like what what have someone okay oh no
what's the guy gonna hit you up like
that you're like oh he's working me
help you out this is how we're gonna
settle it we're going to read dialogue
from the notebook in Asian accents and
we'll figure it out that way that sounds
good so you got your Korean ready not
really
[__] young dude that's hard yeah get
that guy this guy's the best all right
read the blue dialogue the blue yeah
Korean yeah let's see how but but like
make it sound like you're make it sexy
yeah because then this motherfucker's
gonna do like an ajushi and he's gonna
be like why'd your shoes are sexy though
not to a young lady like okay so I'll
paint the Korean guy that I am okay so
you um are in your 30s and you just said
not an audition you just served that's
not an adjective she's like 50s okay all
right these this is dialogue from the
movie yeah you're like
like Korean guy with like nice clothes
you live in a like uh you own the
Squidward a high rise that one's no no
no he doesn't know no no no he owns like
um I don't know like a really famous
you're you're calm your Suave but you
don't take it all too seriously a really
famous mall I wanted everybody knows
that mall and he's lonely and he's like
he finally found the girl of his dreams
aka me and he's like oh my God I have to
have this Mexican chick
all right so like you have to have like
the Suave I don't think any of that is
gonna match the scene but anyways here
goes oh no which one did you pick it's
from notebook right yeah
get ready get the towels the eyebrows
[Music]
what are you
I hate you
I don't see I [__] hate you yeah he
did I don't remember that it's a rewrite
but you said Korean you said Korean but
you gave me the address Sheen I didn't
want that no that's a dirty version to
be fair the guys do yell like that they
do but not like that and I need it that
was really good uh just for directors
but I'm gonna get like a version two I
like it thank you okay okay tone it down
a bit can you tell me can you tell me
could you
be almost depressed depressed depressed
depressed almost like if like these are
your last words can you tell them to not
grab my shirt you're good and could you
really grab Nick sure no not do that
with both hands this time uh-oh yeah you
got to be depressed and bringing them in
real close we're on a tight lens here so
we need them like nose to nose stop
thinking about what everybody wants stop
thinking about what I want why your
parents what
what do you want
sweater
that's not in there
I think I have to change my underwear
yeah she is drenched I'll sit dude that
was sick
I don't either it's not a Calhoun is
that his name Noah yeah Young Noah it's
the Ryan goslinger your turn can you do
a Vietnamese one can yeah here give it
to can I can't do a Vietnamese accent
watch it watch it okay paint the sexiest
Vietnamese guy what's up sexiest
Vietnamese is not sexy by the way stop
saying that bro and you have to get in
this position first no okay full hip
mobility dude oh [__]
do you have a cigarette or something you
see you're already getting into
character I like
that's good go ahead oh here
here
that's nice
no okay another one whoa whoa whoa whoa
let's put the comb down
wow now oh my God
all right that's pretty good dude which
one Young Noah can you flick it too just
a little bit just to get that uh
directors know I would like you to flick
it at the end of your sentence
and then that's it all right great thank
you
um
yeah of course
thank you oh wait it didn't light all
day oh [__]
okay
oh my God I see the smoke
stop thinking about what everybody wants
stop thinking about what I want what
your parents want
do you want
flick it look it
[Applause]
felt hot about that like one one pickup
shot okay what do your parent want flick
them what do your parent want what do
your parent wants flick it okay what
okay good direction
no matter what the your parent what man
that's it look at this cigarette
yeah
you have officially changed my mind
that's [__] hot that's like some man
[__] Vietnamese is definitely it's the
body language it's the glasses that was
Alpha yeah it's Alpha as [__] you didn't
care that you look ridiculous and you
owned it yeah okay Alpha is fun and
panties are soaps I don't want the
Korean anymore and what I got what I got
from it was like he's tired of it if you
don't want this I don't really kill it
that's [__] bro yeah
even more yeah I'm tired of hearing your
complaints and that's the Vietnamese
that's the Vietnamese because Koreans
are always whining and [__] all the time
you're right but the Vietnamese is like
they don't [__] you man
I already know
you know give me two guns I shoot at the
same time
that way that's good you got me bro your
turn I wanted you bro
these scenes are better your turn it's
the same same thing let me get
sunglasses
no you guys don't wear sunglasses
is that a positive or negative
stereotype I don't know that's just not
what I've seen yeah
I won't wear sunglasses but I will act
like the sun is too bright still
another director's note um could you
please blow this at the end of yourself
okay
there's power of dirt hooker [__] juice
and you touched it
there's self juice
that's nasty all right what's my what's
my name where am I at what am I doing
you're on a boat okay you gotta rock you
already gotta start doing this okay
you feel a little seasick but you're
fine
they're gonna help me be sexy
and then you just swap just Swap and
then you deliver it
but you can't laugh you can't laugh
though okay okay
okay okay okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop thinking about what everyone loves
stop thinking about what I want
what your parents want
what do you want Ali
[Laughter]
what is
oh that's disgusting that's really good
bro I thought he was gonna throw up here
drink some ginger ale
ah
even worse so is that in the lead
Filipino dude I still want the big guy
the Vietnam
he's too cool your turn dude I don't
know what accent I could do
Pasadena Chinese
director what do you say um
um it's too hot like it's a really hot
day you're having issues like you're
sweating as you're having issues
breathing like you almost don't remember
your words
I don't know if I could deliver that and
say this with the Asian X at the same
time but I'm gonna try okay you could do
it just yeah wait but you could also do
German I think that's what's gonna cut
off it's not even Asian today
do your Chinese drama yeah you're a
Chinese good Germany and this is your oh
he might just
[Laughter]
it's really hot
this is hard it's hot by the way it's
really hot
go ahead
um let me see here
this is hard to say it okay okay I
changed the scene you're riding a
motorcycle
I think you do it dude you know of all
motorcycles you picked that one yes it's
a sex it's a real sexy mother that's a
scooter bro you're on a motorcycle but
you have a Bluetooth set and this is who
you're talking to
[Laughter]
good thing you're German amazing okay
you need to stop sinking about what
everyone wants
stop thinking about what I want
louder what your parents want oh my God
I feel threatened what do you want Ally
what do you think not bad I feel like if
I don't say yes you're gonna kill my
family is going for
I thought Aryan pride in that one oh
damn in that one I felt like I had SS on
my shoulders while I was going through
zots
re-roll it re-roll it in Chinese now
dude I don't know if I have a Chinese
one just do it
you don't have a Chinese accent after
all these years
just
that's Japanese yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's hard that's Native American yeah
so as I was doing the German accent I
felt in my head I was like this kind of
sounds Indian bro a little bit like it
could be can you do an Indian one that's
a Asian yeah yeah who does can anyone do
it you can do Indian no I cannot you we
need David Dave is so good at it he is
very good you're pretty you're not that
bad what if you did another Vietnamese
no no don't declare it
damn it feels good okay let me see
there's not need it we still need
Chinese to decide and the Chinese one
okay
say some words in Chinese first and get
that feeling up
like do not say that like that yeah yeah
there you go
yeah you got it yeah yeah
just or or do I go or do I go I try to
do a Singaporean yeah there you go that
way like that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
even better even better go ahead go
ahead ready ready wait oh you have to be
on his head wait no no bite like on his
forehead get your feet yeah yeah
uh we're on a phone call but the we keep
cutting out so you have to repeat
yourself
exactly
you're good oh you lie I like that huh
no yes
my head I gotta get my
time you're ready
I'm on the call with you yeah stop
thinking about what everyone wants
stop thinking about what I want all
right sorry you're breaking up oh your
parents
what do you want
I apologize to all my second parties out
there I tried yeah
I tell you
why are you worried about yeah
last one Chinese and then we'll we'll
like make the the charts your Vietnam
that was good dude
you
yourself wrong that Vietnamese is not
yeah you messed up and gotten hot dude
that was the most confident Alpha dude
I've ever seen that's better than Andrew
tank I'm gonna play it back and it's
just we [__] around and we found out
it was good you know the cigarette makes
everybody cool that's why they haven't
been movies damn I gotta start smoking
what's this Chinese prop what's this
Chinese prop what kind of Chinese like a
Cantonese Cantonese oh Cantonese is good
you're chopping onions
here you go there's your knife
Joe had that in his nose by the way
Falcon
you waited son of a [__] everything
here is not safe okay so I'm just
chopping onions and yeah it's crying
you're you're yeah it's the
fumes are really getting to you yeah
but at first at first not
the normal and then in the middle it's
starting to get really worse and towards
the last end of the sentence it's just
you you can't see come on speaker
hello hey
are you there uh-huh okay I need to tell
you about something okay
stop thinking about what
everyone was
I mean talk faster
stop thinking about what I want to talk
slower what your parents want
why you want Ali stop date oh this
aromatic
oh [__]
I've never used an audio
he's like wow what are these that's such
important usually I use the green
scallion
the Maui onion
it's sweet that is hard that was like
doing it's a really hard well he did it
pretty well he's a professional yeah
this guy's good it's almost like he's a
professional I think he's done it before
yeah
that's pretty good I don't know Amanda
that's these one was pretty good hot too
yeah
that was pretty good that's her husband
maybe that's what I am maybe maybe when
he's chopping his shirt yeah you want to
grab your shirt yeah yeah okay whoa dude
this is sensual dude
wait but don't don't like punch crab
to punch me can I get a friend
[Music]
oh
traditional why did you put [__] in your
mouth I'm gonna eat some more muffins
dude
some more [__] put more [__]
I have so much no don't do that to me
Brad Pitt he's like yeah yeah it makes a
better actor that's true while you do
that let me see if this is what is
happening
oh we're way off are they
see the Korean guy had it the best
watch what your parents want
what do you want man what do you want
what it is that's good
it helps yeah it helps stop thinking
you're supposed to have food in your
mouth
I don't like this idea but I like the
idea
stop
[Laughter]
the food You're Gonna swallow it no
don't chew don't you yeah
you're disgusting you're swallowing it
stop thinking
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
stop thinking about what everyone wants
stop thinking about what I want what
your parents want
to do you want Ali
[Laughter]
that's a leading man dude
[Applause]
all right so let's decide on the chart
is number one German no German Asian
singaporeans
[Applause]
can we he got all of us wet in here dude
yeah just don't throw that out I think
that's pretty fair to say so if anybody
in the comments please comment below the
order of sexiness that you believe that
is or just say if your number one pick
is one of those at all please speak your
mind and let us know because in this
room Vietnamese is the sexiest Asian
accent yeah that's right no
[Music]